this is a production of cornell
university thanks everybody this is
uh our fifth week now of the cornell
turf show episode nine masters week
edition
uh and today's guest a master in soils
amounts
in growth uh doug sold that from the
university wisconsin madison's here uh
chat with us today um it's a beautiful
day i don't know if we're gonna have
many live viewers so a lot of you
probably be listening
uh you know through our podcast or
youtube
um so as always we'll get started with a
little weekly wrap-up
uh frank rossi will take us through uh
frank uh anything
any notes on on the last week of weather
here i know it's been a bit abnormal for
us
yeah carl thanks a lot um you know uh
spring is here uh the blue birds are
back and and so
are many of us uh so are many of the old
retired folks that
really make up a good part of the
workforce on a lot of golf courses
around the country you'd be hard-pressed
to find uh community golf courses that
really
don't rely in some way on retired folks
that
are making their way back from maybe
from warmer weather or they're just been
locked up for the winter and many of
them are happy to just get back out in
there
and they're a big part of getting the
work done on the golf course and as you
can see from this young man here
uh perfectly happy to do it with a smile
and then of course there's all the dumb
stuff that happens
you know these are like badges of honor
that we get to see you know the old
turned over top dresser
uh you wonder how it can happen uh but
it does
and then just a shout out to those
people paying attention
uh setting up check plots uh looking at
the pressure that you had through the
winter as we continue to come out of it
and this is from doug's colleague the
wonderful
majestical dr paul koch at the
university of wisconsin but i just want
to
remind you again as i set carl up for
his uh bmp minute here
we are involved with the rochester
institute of technology and the
pollution prevention institute
based uh at rit with funding through the
dec
to uh increase the adoption
of best management practices on golf
courses essentially
uh west of i-81 we have a website set up
where you can
uh learn more about what we're doing you
can sign up you can ask us a question
and one of our recent uh
promotions have been around this poster
that's been published
and that's where i'll pass it off to you
carl and ask you to take over with the
bmp tip of the day yeah so again
in a nod to our guest i've sold out
today we'll be talking about growth and
and a lot about how traffic affects
growth so one of the um
one of the tips today where we're going
to focus on is is targeting traffic
when you're thinking about fertilizers
um so areas that get a lot of traffic
where
you know we think of the pinch points
around greens and between bunkers
those walk-on walk-off areas you know
those those because they receive
more traffic a more dense application of
traffic
uh they probably need more fertilizer
they need more
um of that juice to go a little bit and
there's really a great picture
here from
a green lake state park kind of the
iconic 16th hole there
rtj senior design and and you can really
see this is also the impact of 2020 the
individual cart
riders that we saw so much you can see
that cart traffic
really dense along the side of this
fairway up near the green you can see
all the cart tracks
and this is a situation where we'd say
you know we can see
some thinning from from all that car
traffic on the side even though it's in
the rough
hey we might need to hit that area with
a little bit more nitrogen fertilizer
uh to juice up the growth so it's
growing at the same rate as
maybe some of those areas 10 or 15 yards
off in the rough which are growing just
fine but because there's no traffic
they don't need fertilizer right so
being able to
adjust growth level fertilizer levels
with the traffic levels uh that's one
thing we'll talk about today
and that's our bmp tip of the week
excellent and and
uh before we get to doug we're gonna get
to that traffic
question and i'm gonna we'll set it up
really good for a nice lively
conversation and it's
really starts with how dramatically
early we are
in many parts of the northeast now some
some areas
maybe higher elevations are lagging or
haven't even started to accumulate very
much yet
but a lot of areas now are really
surging ahead
uh of normal conditions you're looking
you know in
in south jersey even in the metropolitan
new york area you're up to two weeks
ahead of normal and so it's hot and
people are burning uh
you know the bar stool uh video that
last week with
bill salanetti and his crew at at the
national golf links
uh doing some of the burning there
here's some burning uh on the right
going on at shore acres in chicago
uh and another picture here uh in the
midwest where some burning's going on
uh it's it's hot and this is a good time
to do this and a lot
of folks are getting out and doing it
now it
looks like we're going to be normal
below normal
and maybe a little bit on the wet side
for the next couple of weeks if we
follow this
a little bit uh i think we are going to
be ahead of normal for temperature
uh we're talking rd guy tano just this
morning he's he's calling for warmer
than normal temperatures and
particularly
cloudy conditions which will keep the
lows
uh well above normal so we're expecting
some rain
coming through the end of the weekend
looks like we should have really good
weather for
us up until sunday and for those of us
that want to watch the masters
living in the northeast we'll have a
rainy sunday to have
an excuse to sit around and watch it now
as we turn to the discussion for today
i pulled off some other uh you know uh
things off of twitter where
people are actively uh redoing their
practice areas
a lot of people out playing wanting to
get started
trying to make a wear tolerant surface
for them in these practice areas
even practice putting greens uh where
sometimes the things that they do
you know can cause this kind of damage
even with spikeless shoes
uh you can see pretty significant damage
from some footwear
if you stand in the same place and
jiggle your feet for 35
40 minutes uh this is typically what
happens now as we've talked about before
and we've showed this slide ad nauseam
looking at the rounds that how it went
last year and what we're already
beginning to see this year
is this you know this pandemic uh
surge of golf with not much else to do
a lot of people went out and played golf
and they're continuing to do that this
spring
and so we're already seeing traffic
rates uh start
increasing remember you know all greens
have these walk-on walk-off
areas you see where the traffic gets
very much
uh concentrated around uh right around
the cup
area and this is why carl and i do the
shoe research
really focused on this particular area
where a lot of the traffic happens
but as you see there's lots a good green
like this
has a lot of entry and exit points you
know you go to some greens there's one
entry point
and one exit point and then of course
that same amount of traffic
gets focused like it does uh around the
cup so
you know obviously on your putting
surfaces this is a pretty
easy way to think about the way traffic
happens but
when it comes to growth right growth
i think uh we would all agree
particularly the kind of growth that we
really need to
keep up with where is very much going to
be related to soil temperature so you
can see
soil temperatures are really now
creeping into
the mid to upper 50s to the southern
part of the region
we're still in the mid to upper 40s here
in central new york and of course as you
go a little bit west
uh it gets a little warmer and cooler as
you get into higher elevations but
it's clear with some warming conditions
coming
this is going to continue to occur now
you got the traffic you've got the
weather you've got the soil
now we've got the grasses right now now
for those of us experiencing traffic
early
uh that have annual bluegrass this is
you know
not necessarily the worst thing because
theoretically annual bluegrass coming
out and growing early or getting started
is going to be well suited and adapted
to that early spring traffic whereas
a lot of the modern creeping bent
grasses that we use again here proposed
by turgeon
many years ago really don't start start
their growth surge until
much later in the season so obviously
you could see
trafficking a grass type is also going
to have a factor now
you know wayne and doug working by his
side and bill working by doug's side and
me being
having a front row seat to it all uh got
to observe
the role that nitrogen plays uh you know
in the way we grow grass right and so if
you had to say anything
uh growth rates very responsive to n a
lot of it is because
we purposely keep nitrogen at a pretty
low
end level i mean wayne used to talk
about before he passed on
about how if you keep giving a bluegrass
or a bent grass nitrogen
they'll keep growing up to 20 25 pounds
and
uh per thousand per year and then of
course we have the idea of
trying to understand how to fertilize
around growth potential
and then there's mowing height doug so
listen now that we're here you and me
i tried to leave a lot of time for
uh you to fill in a lot of color here
but i want to transition
from this where we know the lower we mow
the faster it grows the warmer the soil
maybe the more nitrogen gets released
we know these plants are responsive to
end so
by monitoring clipping production which
is a big topic that i know you've uh
certainly championed and disposed the
best way to do it you've got a
excel growth uh uh
excel chart excel spreadsheet people can
download
to load the clipping data into if they'd
like that plus i think it's in
greenkeeper
as well i want to talk a little bit and
set you up for the
deeper conversation if you will about
nitrogen mineralization and managing it
through
rainfall events when the temperature
says it might not grow right right now
we want it to grow
it doesn't want to grow when we get
rainfall events as carl's demonstrated
in this data here
and we see from clipping data looking at
the vineyard golf club versus our
research
and golf course greens here at cornell
where we're looking at clipping volume
through the growing season
uh you know where we're able to keep it
relatively safe
you know in a not safe consistent you
see early on how it behaves
and then here the vineyard golf club you
see this good indication that carl
showed here from the data that was
collected out there
about the surging and growth and the
amount of growth they get
without growth regulation so doug i
mashed it all
up for you i mashed it all up and i want
to
work at this question what do we know
about
traffic rates grass type weather
that can maybe help us schedule and
target
our nitrogen rates to carl's point about
being more
uh intentional about this so i'm gonna
stop sharing and i'm gonna look at you
and i'm gonna hope you followed me to
some degree there as i
weaved our way through that in a short
period of time
this is the fastest 30 minutes right
carl i'm i'm at the right place
what do you got to say doug what can you
where would you start with trying to
answer this for the average
superintendent
right right well first of all thanks for
having me on it's always a pleasure to
be here um
you guys do such a good job with this
and you you set up
the most right it's the most complicated
thing possible like i i can't answer it
but then that's perfect because we just
talk of all these factors i think
you know the the thing that i've seen in
you know my
relatively short career here is that
we're we're moving towards more
database management and and it's always
in the beginning of of that it's always
a little bit like
i don't know what we're doing you know
but i think the the first thing i'd
start is like you get you just gotta
start tracking your growth
you know just start putting the
clippings in the bucket and i think you
know the thing i hear more than
uh more than anything else is people say
like well it's just a waste of time
because i don't know what to do with it
and yeah that's true but eventually it
won't be you know
and it's easy to do and i you know my
research program's been learning
things from growth all the time and it
is it's super complicated because i
think what
you know let's start with nitrogen and
traffic and growth okay
we found that if you you know for our
research screen
we found that there's a there seems to
be an ideal clipping volume for the
quality that we want to hit
okay and it's about between one and a
half and two
liters of grass per 100 square meter
that's kind of the canadian
unit where the trend started or with
michael woods
it converts the same thing as one to two
quarts
per uh per thousand okay
so now hitting that target if we put no
traffic on our green we didn't have to
fertilize it all
we'd hit it with just the normal soil
but this is in the summer
this is like right in the optimum bent
grass growing season
then when we started put traffic on it
if we put a normal level of traffic we
had to fertilize about
a two tenths of a pound every other week
to hit that growth target
and then if we if we simulated like just
traffic around the cup
you know all the time really intense
traffic we had to fertilize at
double that so 0.4 pounds every other
week
almost a pound a month to to replace to
hit that growth target
so now that's the mid-summer you know
that but when we when we're talking now
it's spring the grass isn't growing it's
you're not going to hit those growth
targets now because there's temperature
limit
so you know bill cruiser's done some
great work he's got the nebraska
nitrogen responsiveness model that tells
you
if you put down nitrogen now you know uh
because it's cold you're only going to
see let's say
70 percent of what you'd expect in the
optimum growing season so
we're starting to learn you know how
weather affects the growth how the
traffic affects the growth and i have a
phd student that's doing
uh really cool work modeling that growth
so eventually down the road you'll be
able to say
we know what what the growth targets are
we see what the weather and the
nitrogen's all doing to influence the
growth and hopefully you can make really
solid decisions based off that
so what would you tell somebody you know
that summer
on bank grass it's spring they're
playing golf like crazy
is there any way to over are there
nitrogen sources i can use
or things i could have done in the fall
that might
increase my traffic tolerance a little
earlier
then i'd like then i would normally need
it in a non-pandemic recovery rebound
uh growth year yeah yeah that's good you
know we
this is bent grass is not very traffic
tolerant
right so and it's an area that we need
to continue doing more work on but that
said the things i would do
is i'd mow early and often so mowing
stimulates that growth
so you know we like to say mow as least
as possible well that's a
summer optimum growing season
recommendation i would say in the spring
you actually
you want to mow now do i have the
research data that says that
conclusively no but i'm you know i'm
just saying this is what i think i would
do
mow it a lot uh and use
uh like a nitrate-based fertilizer
um if you use urea you gotta wait for
microbes to break it down and convert it
so if you go with something like a
potassium nitrate
uh you may get um or uan is urea and
ammonium nitrate it's got all three
nitrogen sources in it
you know urea is cool because it's a
really good foliar fertilizer it'll get
in through the leaves and the nitrate
will come up through the roots in these
cooler
soil temps so why do i like nitrate what
about ammonium sources uh
i mean obviously we're not buying
ammonium nitrate you like ammonium
sulfate
is there any value to ammonium
ammoniacal sources at this time maybe to
uh does does up is uptake any different
from the soil from your
perspective yeah so the the so
ammonium's toxic
uh so if the if you give them if you
give the plant a bunch of ammonium
it uh it can't store it so it
it's bet ammonium's best like during
active growth when it's just
pounding it into growth in proteins so
if you give it nitrate
it can throw it in the vacuole if it
doesn't want it
and and it's so that's one of the
reasons that we like
nitrate in these cool soil temperatures
but you know keep in mind you know
you can shoot yourself in the foot by
slinging out
nitrate trying to hit a growth target
because the plant's just not growing so
you know you have to always in the
spring in the fall
just slow and low you know tenth of a
pound here
you know don't be going out with high
rates trying to trying to force
growth because you can you can get in
trouble there but spoon feed it with low
rates
so so i know you've looked at this in
the fall um
where we're saying meter off your end
rates based on
et we are in a particularly dry period
uh
in the springtime for much of us uh up
here in the northeast
there is some rain coming how much does
the
i think art was saying somewhere between
a quarter and three quarters of an inch
of e.t
is uh happening through the week now so
not a lot of vt but
some how much does keeping it
you know the ep or the lack of it going
to affect
how much nitrogen comes into the plant
and is able to stimulate growth
yeah that's exactly right et is the way
that the nitrogen gets
gets transported to the root so it can
take it up now three quarters of an inch
that's not bad
you know you're getting you're starting
to get some pretty good water movement
and so
you know the thing the thing i would
just say is just keep your rates at a
tenth
or less and and the plant can take that
up and that's what we found in
at least in the fall in those cold
temperatures october november
you start getting over a tenth and the
plant just can't there's not enough
water flow the plant can't take it up
yeah two two things here one is you know
there's the putting surfaces
that it's practical to take up clippings
but as carl showed in that picture we're
talking about roughs and fairways now
where car traffic's getting to be an
issue and
you know what do i got to do get a
rotary and start doing bill cryser
when he was in eighth grade collecting
clippings off the lawn
uh how am i gonna monitor growth doug in
these bigger areas pal i'm open for
suggestions because we don't have any
really conclusive ideas how would you
even begin to approach such a thing
yeah there's got to be so i've thought
about this for fairways for a bit and
i think i think you know it's you just
have to
uh delineate an area uh a length
so like how we do it on our research
plots is we lay down we have a chain
just like if it's like a field goal
chain right it's got
it ours is like five feet long and we
put our rotary mower and we mow five
feet
and then we we measure the grass that we
got in that five feet because i don't
want to mow the whole plot
and if i remove all the clippings from
the thing then that messes up the study
so just pick yeah you can just pick a
strip you know
and now we're talking more labor more
effort so maybe
it's when when we do have more
information where that's we're gonna
make that worth your while to mow a
strip
uh of the same length of a fairway throw
the clippings in the bucket
and you know you it's a you can do the
same thing with your
with uh uh ruffmore but it's gonna have
to be somebody walking
right you put the collect the clippings
from the from the back
chute throw them in a bucket um so again
more labor than it is for
greens where we're already collecting
clippings but i think that's
that's what it's going to have to be and
so the other part of this
is what is a ritual through northern
climates is the
early season use of potential growth
regulating
products and we had our our uh pal bill
on
um and talking about this from a pgr
perspective
uh we are sort of shooting ourselves in
the foot here a bit
uh when we're sort of wanting growth and
having these growth regulators how do
you reconcile our
sort of routine use of these things in
the spring
and the need for growth and the nitrogen
rate you might use to balance the two if
possible
yeah it's a tough one again a lot of
times when we're doing these research
studies we
take out those factors you know so like
in our traffic study
pgrs weren't in effect and so we you
know we did a
we did a golf course fairway study with
bluegrass and we put some
we put some heavy traffic on it we put
growth regulators on it we measured the
growth and
i mean we know uh regulators on
bankruptcy don't get too
worked up about because they don't
unless it's trim it they don't do a
really
good job you know we're talking 10 20
regulation
there's reasons to do it but it's not
it's not like when you do it on your
fairways and you're talking 50 to 80
percent
regulation or you're roughs right um
so you have to keep an eye on that and
the over sprays you know so i would say
the first thing to do is just
uh instead of spraying the entire
putting green surface and over spraying
into the collars and surrounds
stop and miss partial portions of your
putting green
you know so you don't have any over
spray in those in those early spring
times but yeah go ahead frank well i was
gonna say
i thank you for making the segway really
easy to
uh the last part of our conversation
which is targeted
targeted nitrogen applications if you
look at that slide
where the traffic is focused on a
putting green you know historically
uh craig chris trittibaugh's daughter
olive not withstanding very you know her
crayons that he used to do this
it's generally not considered to be uh
prudent to use different end rates on
the same putting surface
and yet if i follow what you've just
told me
if i'm getting more traffic in
particular areas i better get more
growth in those areas
and if i'm using growth regulators i
cannot spray in certain places but
what about using differential end rates
on a putting surface uh to
compensate for where traffic might get
more focused
yeah you got to do it you know i showed
that slide uh with the crayons i had a
talk in the
northern great lakes superintendents
association the northern wisconsin
northern michigan guys
and afterwards superintendent came up to
me um
and said my dad was a superintendent and
uh
we did this back in the back in the 50s
and 60s you know
he he'd say hey go uh go spread some
extra fertilizer on this part
of the green right and so i think you
know that's how you water too
so i think if you know if you talk to
the superintendent's listening
everybody's probably done differential
fertilization at some point and
it's just like we just need to start
thinking about doing it more precisely
or more guided but yeah
you get those high traffic areas they
probably need twice as much
more as fertilizer you got areas on
putting greens that don't need
fertilizer at
all you know and so it just like areas
that you never water
you never hand water them and areas that
are always wet right so it's the same
it's the same concept and i think the
harder part is we just don't have the
soil moisture probe to tell us exactly
where the water's going like we do with
nitrogen and traffic
just a little bit more heart it's harder
yeah and there's so there's two things
there one is
the consequences of putting n where you
don't want it or need it
um has consequences in the amount of
sand
uh we've got a sling number one number
two
the fear that differential and in some
of these
heavily cupped areas might lead to
changes in playing performance
right carl thinks he can notice things
on greens that maybe
an extra tenth of a pound uh might might
uh might suggest how do you answer the
concern
on green speed or uh obviously the easy
one with uh
with less and less need for sand we
think
yeah that's exactly right and you know
that's what we're trying to do here is
we're
i bet we're putting down too much sand
you know because it's it's just like
it's
everything is with precision turf as has
the same story
is that it's always better to be a have
a little bit more
than to have not enough right so our
default is let's let's just cover our
bases put a little bit more water on
and then as we get these moisture probes
we can fine tune that
with the sand it's better right now
we're in the spot where like you know
extra top dressing
sure isn't going to hurt anything but uh
if we can get by with less it's going to
be better and
we need you know same thing with
nitrogen i would say
we got to do the studies to say how this
differential n
fertilization uh affects the
the characteristics of surface i'm not
worried at
all at all i mean i would say bring it
on carl there's no way you're going to
notice what we're going to do the end
result
the end result is going to be more
consistency because what you're doing is
compensating for the diff
the variation that's already there so
you're going to even things out that's
i i have a high degree of confidence in
that um
that's perfect and what a great segue
carl how about that
so so you got any how about questions or
maybe comments you might have about what
we've talked about so far
i i think one of the comments i've made
about just the number of factors that go
into growth doug i know you're
you're doing that research where you
kind of plug in all the variables and it
spits out you know all these
environmental variables pgrs fertilizer
mowing height
and you're trying to feed all that into
a system to try and get it to
spit out what's important you know one
of the questions craig
crin had early in the season we used
growing degree days
just a strict measure of temperature to
kind of time our seed heads or
pre-applications and he's saying this
year growing degree days aren't really
lining up with some of the phenological
indicators to stuff like the forsynthias
he's asking you know which one should i
trust this year
uh what would you guys think about that
just growing degree days strictly a
temperature based
versus you know logical indicator
all right so i'll answer this for
crabgrass and i'll let frank say what he
thinks about the poa seed heads but so
the forsythia crap is our top crab grass
indicator and
what what's actually the best indicator
is your soil temp because that's what
the
crabgrass seed is living in so i would
keep for crabgrass and
pre-emergent i would be keeping an eye
on the soil temp i don't know the answer
to that whether air temps or soil temps
are
are more important for annual bluegrass
what do you think frank
um i think that seed head development
remains elusive
uh for us to understand i think ascu's
work that started spraying it in the
fall
revolutionized our thinking about when
this is initiated from a cell
organization perspective and that's what
we have to disrupt
with these things that are primarily
division inhibitors they
they don't allow the cells to divide so
so
this a complicated question i think
that's why those
late fall apps are better uh i got a
different question to craigs
uh is can you use phenological
indicators
as ways of uh triggering some nitrogen
application timings or maybe some
nitrogen uh responses or mineralization
of nitrogen in the soil can we use any
of those
uh phenological indicators you've ever
seen as a means of determining when
i'm start going to start to get
contribution
yeah i think so that's where we're
headed so that like the the phd student
uh chio zhou is doing
this work with bent grass growth and you
know we're starting to like
the the weather factors that matter the
most are relative humidity and
temperature like
three days before so it's like that
previous day weather that's influencing
the growth
into the future and i think so that's
what we're going to learn is we're going
to start to be able to just
use these new data crunching tools to
be to know more about the growth pattern
so you know the classic pictures you
showed in this slideshow the
the bimodal distribution of growth like
that's great on a
on a climate basis uh but what we're
going to be able to do is just look at
your weather
and some of your conditions and say this
is your this is where you're at
in growth and then you can make your
decisions from there
perfect and and just to wrap up craig's
question
you know generally i like phenological
indicators because they tend to indicate
the whole environment better and
and and doug will tell you and even bill
will tell you they
messed around with a lot of models
before they came up with the right base
temperature and the right in
you know intervals and and growing
degree days are these artifacts we
create to try to predict as a proxy
for biological activity and phenological
activity is a biological activity and if
it can be timed up i think
because it takes into account many
things
and we see that manifested in urban heat
islands where
urban areas the forsythias are weeks
ahead of rural forsythias so
i always like phenological indicators
craig and with that
doug always great to see you pal thanks
so much for taking the time
carl thanks for hosting yeah we'll get
everybody out of here
uh masters thursday it'll be exciting to
watch the
the firmness of the course looks like
it's pretty firm this week so everybody
uh you know enjoy that justin johnson's
gonna be my pick this week
uh so you can go bet money well you
can't bet anymore 10 minutes already
sorry
give it to you too late but uh everybody
thanks thanks to 10 we'll see you guys
tomorrow
evan masket mass skitty i think we're
gonna have to pronounce that right but
he's gonna have some cool stuff on
infield skins tomorrow
but uh until then yep we'll see you guys
uh tomorrow thanks everybody
thanks a lot man thank you take care see
you carl
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu